y'est je me suis fait pirater mon compte
facebook non je suis content parce que
ça vous a pas que ça m'arrive
vous pensez peut-être que les pirates de
facebook c'est les mecs qui ont des
grosses lunettes et kif qui sont des
petits génies de l'informatique et aux
seins c'est pas ça en fait ces mecs là
c'est soit des amis ou des collègues qui
s'empare de ton pc pour écrire un petit
statut un peu nul en général en ta
défaveur parce que sinon ça sert à rien
aujourd'hui je vais faire les courses
avec malou le les mecs qui piratent
dépens de facebook c'est toujours les
mêmes lors en général c'est des mecs qui
sont pas très marrant ils font pas trop
de blagues et tout d'un coup il se lâche
tu vois c'est pas compliqué en général
toujours la même truc qu'ils écrivent oh
là là je suis homosexuel j'aime bien
faire des fellations à des hommes car je
suis homosexuel oh j'aime beaucoup les
fallu six fils c'est vrai que là il
pense que ta réaction à va être positive
tu vois un joueur tu vas rire et au je
suis un homosexuel finale je t'invite
offline giec et nous en tant que
victimes de ces pirates on a tout le
temps la même réaction
dis donc je ne savais pas que j'avais un
ami geof moi je ne me suis pas homo mais
je respecte les liens faut vraiment
arrêter parce que déjà d'un on croit pas
enfin le dire moi jamais j réécrire
tiens tiens je crois que je suis
homosexuel faut que j'avertis semaines a
mis tout de suite mais je me suis dit
que les homosexuels entre eux et peuvent
pas faire cela gnu go
et heureusement que les pirates de
facebook avec la rue moment ils font pas
un one man show parce que bon tout le
monde aime faire dans la salle moi la
mienne sur son statut facebook
jacquet votre nom mais voilà ce que je
veux dire c'est que donc voilà j'y pense
depuis un moment j'aimerais bien essayer
de réunir un peu les forces est de créer
une sorte front anti pirates de facebook
mais si jamais vous pensez comme moi que
vous vous sentez concerné par cette
philosophie
contactez moi en fait j'ai un nouveau
blog c'est norman fait des vidéos pour
le gamin au revoir
bonjour hugo